As one of the most ambitious crossover events
in history, Avengers: Infinity War featured
a miles-long cast roster that brought together
all of the corners of the sprawling Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
Black Widow, Black Panther, Iron Man, the
Guardians of the Galaxy — the whole crime-fighting
crew was there!
Well, except for Hawkeye, Ant-Man, and, for
the most of the movie, the Hulk.
In the first few minutes of Infinity War,
Thanos defeats the Hulk during a fight on
the refugee ship that fled from Asgard at
the end of Thor: Ragnarok.
The not-so-jolly green giant didn't appear
in the film again after that— and we finally
know why.
According to the commentary track from the
digital release of Avengers: Infinity War,
the Hulk wasn't M.I.A.
because he was ashamed that Thanos pummeled
him to the ground.
It's actually even more twisted than that:
The Hulk is getting sick of coming to Banner's
aid every time he and the Avengers need assistance
in the form of brute force.
"I have an army…"
"We have a hulk."
Joe Russo explained:
"People speculated whether there was some
fear on the Hulk's part about having to face
Thanos again.
But I think ultimately it's that he's tired
of playing hero to Bruce Banner."
It's easy to see why viewers would rally behind
the idea that the Hulk was in some way emotionally
bruised after his scuffle with Thanos.
The Hulk staying in hiding because he was
feeling fear?
That's not exactly a common occurrence when
it comes to our temperamental green-skinned
buddy — his whole schtick is getting angry
and jumping into a fight, after all.
"Hulk, stop!
Just for once in your life don't smash …
"Big monster!"
Fear is the opposite of what the Hulk is about,
so it's only natural to latch onto something
so rare.
The Hulk experiencing an emotion he's rarely
felt before and not fully understanding how
to process it is a solid theory that makes
for a satisfying character arc.
But the real reason for the Hulk's absence
is way more fulfilling, for two reasons.
It gives Banner's alter-ego the autonomy to
become more than just the muscular manifestation
of Banner's dark inner disquiet, and it pushes
Banner to stop relying on the Hulk to save
him from sticky situations.
While many Marvel fans have believed Banner
to be constantly trying to hold the Hulk in,
it looks like the tables are beginning to
turn as the Hulk has finally put his huge
green foot down.
Russo elaborated on that dynamic even more:
"There's a host body that is being fought
over by two distinct personalities who hate
each other.
[...] We thought an interesting direction
to take him in is, well, what if Banner, who
typically uses the Hulk to solve crisis situations,
what if the Hulk were no longer interested
in solving those problems for Banner?
So, the relationship is becoming increasingly
dysfunctional..."
Russo's explanation here shoots down all other
possible reasons as to why Banner couldn't
turn into the Hulk in Infinity War — including
the suggestion that he was too angry to transform
or that he blamed himself for what happened
on the Asgardian ship.
But it also stamps out one of the more thought-provoking
theories surrounding the character.
Another unusual fan theory suggested that
the Hulk was missing from Infinity War because
Loki was actually masquerading as Banner.
That would certainly explain why there weren't
any "Hulk out" moments.
But given that Russo goes on to focus specifically
on Banner and the Hulk's tense relationship,
that theory effectively falls apart as well.
After the jaw-dropping ending of Avengers:
Infinity War, we've been operating under the
impression that Avengers 4 will rip out more
hearts and feature more intensity than previously
thought possible.
Now, it looks like Bruce Banner and the Hulk's
turbulent dynamic will be a major part of
that chaos.
"Haha, you guys are screwed now."